New York Governor Andrew Cuomo says
today his state will begin what he calls
the most aggressive antibody testing
program in the country Cuomo says New
York can conduct up to 2,000 antibody
tests per day to determine who has been
infected our chief medical correspondent
dr. Jon LaPook joins us with more on
that
so Jon let's start with the antibody
test he says there are two different
kinds what are they and how are they
different well the two different annum
again remember that the antibody is to
see whether you've been exposed
whether you perhaps have protection it's
not to show whether you have active
infection that's the PCR that's the
nasal and throat swab the two types of
antibody tests are the traditional Eliza
al is a which look we have similar
things for measles mumps rubella it's
technically not a hard thing to do and
it tells you sort of the degree of
antibody that you have the other is a
more rapid test that is looks more like
a pregnancy test and you see whether
there's a line there or not there's a
control that says okay it's working and
then if there's a line horizontally it
says okay you have an antibody it
doesn't tell you how much antibody so
who can get the test everybody wants to
have that test right I think there's not
anybody in the country yeah maybe there
are a couple who don't want to have it
they want to know gee that cold that I
had six weeks ago I wonder if that was
coronavirus and whether I might have
some degree of protection but right now
it's slowly rolling out I I know my
sister is up in near Saratoga and she
said there was a Price Chopper she sent
me a little Facebook posting where
people were lined up hopefully far
enough apart from each other inside to
try to wait they were waiting for hours
to get this antibody test over the
weekend so I know everybody wants to get
it and that the reason for it is that we
have had this friction between do we
save the economy or do we try to handle
Kovan 19 well you can get your arms
around both if you find out for example
that you were have antibody you were
exposed then it's possible there's a big
asterisk we're not sure how protected
you are but it's possible you could
consider then going back to work that
still has to be worked out
do you have any concerns about the
accuracy of the test
absolutely so at the very beginning
there wasn't that much control a lot of
them dozens and dozens got rolled out
and we know that there were false
positives and false negatives I heard of
one for example that tested positive
just if you've been exposed to any
member of the coronavirus family
remember that the corona virus is a
family of viruses and and about 1/3 of
the common cold is a corona virus so the
last thing you want is a false positive
or false negative it's better to have no
test than to have an inaccurate test the
FDA is really only a handful
realistically John do you think we can
go back to life as normal without an
effective treatment or a vaccine and I'm
wondering what you think is a doctor
when you see the protests that are
clearly not practicing social distancing
yeah I think that it's going to be a new
normal
unless until we get a vaccine that we
know is effective that's the ultimate
backstop but that's at least about a
year away and we're not sure there's no
guarantee it's gonna work until then I
think the reason why we need this
testing which is both the PCR looking to
see if you have the infection or the
antibody is to get our arms around to
find out who's got it who doesn't have
it and we can try to slowly try to
reopen parts of the country without that
we really are not going to know what
we're doing going to be driving blind
all right John thank you very much